falls eines tages die historiker zion
meinung kommen sollten
er hat seine sache anständig gemacht bin
ich ganz zufrieden
das würden wohl auch die meisten
deutschen sagen dass helmut schmidt
seine sache anständig gemacht hat heute
ist er im alter von 96 jahren zu hause
gestorben und anständig das ist ein wort
das zum hamburger altkanzler gut passt
vom sturmfluten krisenmanager zum
bundeskanzler und später zum
intellektuellen gewissen des landes
wir wollen in dieser phoenix runde an
helmut schmidt erinnern ich begrüße sie
ganz herzlich guten abend und das sind
meine gäste kurt beck ist bei uns von
2006 bis 2008 vorsitzender der spd lange
jahre ministerpräsident von rheinland
pfalz und jetzt vorsitzender der
friedrich ebert stiftung herzlich
willkommen
und ich begrüße günther beckstein alle
csu zeitweise kollege von kurt beck als
ministerpräsident von bayern und davor
lange jahre bayerischer staatsminister
des innern
guten abend christian ströbele von
bündnis 90 die grünen im bundestag und
zu zeiten helmut schmidt aber eher auf
der anderen seite nämlich als anwalt von
mitgliedern der roten armee fraktion
ulrich deppendorf journalist im moment
schon in pension aber bis zu diesem
frühjahr chefredakteur und leiter des
ard-hauptstadtstudios
herr beck als sie heute die nachricht
gehört haben man hatte ja damit
gerechnet was war das erste gefühl was
sie daran
also ich muss sagen ich habe gedacht er
hat es geschafft denn wir haben in den
letzten tagen immer wieder nachrichten
gekriegt wie schlecht es ihm ginge und
wenn man selber am totenbett teil dann
schon einmal gestanden hatten sowieso
und kampf in der endphase ist das erste
gefühl war in seinem alter
er hat jetzt geschafft und dann war viel
anerkennung und tun
ein stiller respekt da den ich wirklich
empfunden haben nicht nur ausgesprochen
was war helmut schmidt versehen
er war jemand der auf eine ganz
besondere weise auf einen damals jungen
sozialdemokraten eingewirkt hat er war
nicht gerade jemand mit dem man sich
umarmt hätte aber jemand der durchaus
eine sensibilität für junge leute hatte
ich werde unsere erste begegnung nie
vergessen dass wir in london der
festhalle sehr sehr viele menschen und
meine mit kollegen die damals bewerber
für den landtag waren haben alle die
welt erklärt und er saß sichtlich
genervt oben auf der bühne und hat sich
das angehört
das kannst du nicht machen und habe dann
über ein problem des zweiten weltkriegs
moderat walzik westerland an der deutsch
französischen grenze berichtet und ihn
gebeten etwas zu unternehmen
das hat ihm dann offensichtlich
angesprochen hat mich zu sich gebeten
und das habe ich ja wie ein ritterschlag
empfunden
herr beckstein die csu war lange
sozusagen der lieblingsfeind von helmut
schmidt man erinnert sich an den
wahlkampf strauß schmidt er ist vor
allem bei den deutschen aber in
erinnerung geblieben als ein grosser
staatsmann und unglaublich beliebt
geworden als kann es auf einigen
nachhinein auch was war für sie also ich
selber war ja für die jahre fast zwei
jahrzehnte in der sicherheitspolitik
darum denke ich natürlich war helmut
schmidt zunächst mal das was in diesem
bereich geleistet hat der einsatz beim
hamburger hochwasser wenn man selber mal
in eine einsatzzentrale war weiß man
welche anforderungen des stellt und dass
helmut schmidt dann die situation sofort
scharf erkannt hat gesehen hat er seine
eigenen kräfte nicht reichen
die bundeswehr angefordert hat damals
ohne jede rechtsgrundlage war ganz ganz
mutige entscheidungen die im nachhinein
richtig waren
wenn es schief gegangen wäre dann wäre
die öffentliche anerkennung nicht ganz
so groß gewesen
oder dann später natürlich mogadischu
die entscheidung gegenüber der raf nicht
nachzugeben
dass die opposition mit in den
krisenstab geholt hat die alle geheimen
beratungen mitgeführt hatte ganz ganz
gescheitert dass daraus nicht
politischer streit entstehen kann
weil die anderen allesamt eingebunden
waren dass es sich bei der nachrüstung
ganz klar auf die seite gestellt hat die
russen dürfen nicht an den militärischen
vorsprung bekommen
trotz der aufstände in der spd trotz der
aufstände in einer evangelischen kirche
hat ganz klare linie gehabt
persönliche bemerkung dass eine ich habe
mich mit ihm anfang 2004 mal unterhalten
und das über die frage gesinnungsethik
verantwortung tätig und da hat er mir in
einer ganz ganz eindrucksvollen
glasklare sache gesagt der politiker
muss an die verantwortung tätig denken
max weber ist ja der klassiker der
politologie er hat mir darüber eine
vorlesung gehalten und mit eigenen
erkenntnissen noch vertieft und ganz
persönlich hat ja viel größere
hörprobleme noch als ich aber dass er
dann sich nicht in ein schneckenhaus
zurückgezogen hat daß ich öffentlich
gezeigt hat trotz dieser probleme finde
ich ganz toll ist ein vorbild für viele
andere
viele trauen sich das nicht mehr
er hatte den mut auch zu seinen
behinderungen zu stehen als natürlich
wir waren damals die lieblingsfeinde wir
haben ihn attackiert er hat uns aber
natürlich auch hat erklärt aber ganz
ganz große respekt auf die attacken
kommen wir gleich sicherlich auch noch
sie haben eben gesagt unnachgiebig
gerade auch in der zeit eben mit der
roten armee fraktion da kommen wir zu
ihnen herr ströbele da waren sie ganz
klar auf der ganz anderen seite als sie
heute die nachricht vom tod helmut
schmidts gehört haben gab es dann auch
respekt nach all den jahren und
anerkennung für das was helmut schmidt
war
naja ich glaube ich unterscheide sehr
stark zwischen neben helmut schmidt
der ist zum ende seiner kanzlerschaft
hier als politiker das gegenüber der
hauptgegner gewesen ist und dem helmut
schmidt für den ich war auch uhr achtung
habe jetzt im hohen alter
wenn ich mit dem ersten anfangen
natürlich war er damals ich sage
geradezu ein wichtiger grund warum die
sozialen bewegungen entstanden sind mit
hunderttausenden demonstranten und
teilnehmern also die anti-akw-bewegung
die anti raketen bewegung die
ökologiebewegung das waren bewegung
gegen seine politik ebenso die straße
getrieben haben und aus denen ja dann
die grünen geworden sind aus protest
gegen diese spd politik die ja dann zum
schluss seiner kanzlerschaft auch in der
spd sehr verbreitet gewesen ist also ich
treffe heute immer wieder viele kollegen
auch im bundestag die sagen sie haben
angefangen politisch zu denken als gegen
helmut schmidt demonstriert und meinen
dann da haben wir gemeinsam danach war
ja eine zeit lang da kann habe ich wenig
von ihm wahrgenommen
jetzt in den letzten jahren war ich
immer wieder erstaunt dass er position
vertreten hat und mutig diebe gegen den
mainstream gerichtet waren also zum
beispiel in der russland politik in
vielen konnte ich so anja das sehe ich
ähnlich oder auch in der europapolitik
da habe ich respekt vor ihm und ich
glaube der wird auch fehlen in nächster
zeit wenn es darum geht auch sachen
auszusprechen die vielleicht gar nicht
so rein passen die allgemeine wahl
hätten doch wir haben sie helmut schmidt
erlebt auch gerade in der
auseinandersetzung mit seiner partei was
welche rolle musste er da spielen
helmut schmidt hat leute das erlebt was
in der spd häufiger schon mal passiert
dass große führer einer partei wie der
spd die mutig sind die bestimmte
beschlüsse bestimmte ideen haben
schwierigkeiten haben mit ihrer partei
das war aber auch bei willy brandt das
war ganz stark bei helmut schmidt und
hat sich dann fortgeführt letzten endes
aubis gerhard schröder und dennoch ist
er stehen geblieben hat für seine sache
gekämpft hat die den nachrichten
nachrüstungsbeschluss durchgeführt er
war glaube ich einer der mutigsten
politiker denen wir hier in deutschland
hatten
er war auch ein politiker der meinen
berufsstand nicht besonders gemocht hat
das viele anderen auch ein
aber im nachhinein glaube ich wenn man
vieles sieht was er an gedacht hat ist
eingetreten
und ich war beeindruckt von den letzten
auftritten von ihnen da jetzt mehr aus
sowie ein ströbele ich werde nicht
vergessen den parteitag im dezember 2011
hier in berlin als helmut schmidt kurz
paar tage vor seinem 93
geburtstag eine flammende rede für
europa gehalten hat von nationalstaaten
nationalismus gewarnt hat lohnt sich
wirklich noch einmal nachzulesen gerade
auch gelohnt sie nachzumachen
ganz wichtig und das war ein vermächtnis
und das ist mir heute eingefahren aber
ich möchte ihnen einem punkt
widersprechen
diese an die kanzler willy brandt
schmidt bei schröder ist ihre partei
nicht mehr mit gegangen aber war das
noch sozialdemokratische politik und
waren das wirklich die zukunftsentwürfe
also nehmen sie mal die atomkraft heute
ist es völlig selbstverständlich in
deutschland also auch bei der cdu/csu zu
hause dass das von übel ist und dass man
das mädchen will dass man das auch oder
die ganze ökologiebewegung und solche
bemerkung
wer visionen hat soll zum abgehen das
war beleidigend
das war das war aber helmut schmidt
damit musste man leben dass er solche
bemerkung machte
letzten endes hat er durchaus selber auf
visionen gehabt
immerhin gehen wir nach europa nehmen
wir die europa politik nehmen wir auch
das was er zu russland gesagt hat am
ende nehmen wir china ich meine hat auf
der anderen seite auch sehr kontroverse
positionen gehabt natürlich auch was
ihre partei angeht wenn er so
menschenrechtsfragen ging da war er
zurückhaltender als alle anderen aber
trotzdem frage auch an den
sozialdemokraten in dieser runde man
sagt ja jetzt frau merkel macht so viel
sozialdemokratische politik die ist
manchmal wie falsch und weiter das hat
man schmidt auch oft gesagt haben auch
viele konservativere gesagt also wenn
der in anderen partei würde ich den ja
sogar wählen passt ja gar nicht so zur
spd
also eher dem ja immer selber
widersprochen
ich hab das mehrfach gehört insoweit
glaube ich hat schon einfach dazu gehört
auch dass man sich auseinander gesetzt
hat und entschuldigungen würde dass ich
ein grüner darüber beschwert dass eine
partei sich versuch gegen den jeweiligen
regierungschef aus den eigenen reihen
durchzusetzen ist ja zunächst mal nichts
vorwerfbares beiden seiten nicht und es
ist ja auch nicht so gewesen
zu dieser zeit dass jemand die wahrheit
für sich gepachtet hat und doch wir
hatten läuft na ja das glaube ich nicht
so einfach nicht recht in
nachrüstungsbeschluss hat sie nicht
rechnet ganz landwirt nicht recht weil
das ergebnis waren anderes am ende und
ich bin damals eine wenig gewesen die
für den nachrüstungsbeschluss als junger
mensch gewesen ist wie dafür von meiner
partei nicht zum delegierten zu dem
bundesparteitag gewählt worden
sonst werden 15 stimmen dafür gewesen
aber man muss dorian dürfen um sollte
fragen und ich finde das rechtfertigt
kein urteil dass der eine sozusagen
außerhalb der eigenen reihe
steht über die frage atomkraft ja das
ist wohl wahr wir haben alle damit mal
illusionen verbunden und haben uns eines
besseren belehren lassen müssen
aber ob die einen immer alles vorher
richtig wissen und die anderen es nicht
da auch auf seiner bemerkung multikulti
ganz abschätzig ist eigentlich keine
demokratische gesellschaften den
ausspruch kenne jetzt nicht geben aber
ich bin ja nicht da jetzt um jede
aussage wunde von schwindsucht darum
sohn künstlichen keil jetzt zwischen die
sozialdemokratie und ihn zu reiten das
halte ich für nicht in ordnung es war
eine heftige auseinandersetzung aber es
war eine auseinandersetzung unter sagen
warum denken sie ist helmut schmidt
letztendlich so beliebt geworden so in
den letzten jahren was ist das wohl die
bürger sagen ja das ist derjenige der
den wir als kanzler am meisten verehren
ich glaube weil er am ende ja doch sehr
mutige formulierungen gefunden artikel
geschrieben hat er hat sich sehr
kritisch zu griechenland frage ob es hat
er hat darauf schon gewarnt vor dem
zerfallenden europa er hat gesagt wir
müssen mit russland anders umgehen als
es vielleicht im augenblick auch getan
wird also da hat er glaube ich und seine
wirtschaftskompetenz die war natürlich
irgendwo haftete an ihm
das hat er gläubiger gehabt so von
seiner kanzlerschaft bis hinüber dass er
immer wieder als derjenige angesehen
wurde
der in wirtschaftsfragen besonders
gut war bzw auch vertrauen genossen hat
er damals dieses land durch schwierige
zeiten geführt
hohe arbeitslosigkeit und anderes
ölkrise ich glaube das haben auch die
älteren unter den menschen nicht so so
ganz vergessen
ich glaube auch dass es wird jedem
führenden politiker so gehen sie werden
immer erst jahre später bekommen sie
sozusagen das zurück ein positives
signal
auch daran hat wechseln weil schmidt
eben und vielleicht auch ähnlich wie
strauß jemand war der eben ein macher
war ein trinker jemand der kanten hat
und ecken und nicht einfach so
stromlinienförmig also es war ganz
offensichtlich dass er ein
intellektueller war der schnell gedacht
hat schnell manchmal auch verletzt
verletzend geredet hat aber jeder musste
ihm zubilligen dass er von seinem fach
was versteht und zum beispiel die frage
in der damaligen wirtschaftskrise fünf
prozent inflation sind mir lieber als
wenn arbeitslosigkeit um sie zu trösten
das war natürlich etwas was bei uns auf
härteste kritik gestoßen ist also von
daher war für uns schon klar dass er ein
sozialdemokrat ist er eben versucht in
der krise das zu tun was unbedingt
notwendig ist aber er hat eine andere
politik gemacht als die union
aber man musste jemand für schlichtweg
respekt zu billigen
auch dann und gerade dann wenn man mit
ihm im clinch gelegen war
dass er dann später wir lange nicht mehr
aktiv gewesen ist dass er etwas
verbunden hat was sag ich ganz selten
ist nämlich intellektuelle zu sein und
gleichzeitigen praktische politik zu
machen normalerweise akten doch dass die
politiker alle nur pragmatisch denken
langfristig heißt allenfalls bis zum
nächsten wahltag und die philosophen die
sind das was weiß ich die nur vom von
den visionen reden
schmidt hat im alter beides miteinander
verbunden
die erfahrungen des pragmatischen
politikers mit dem was intellektuelle
philosophische grundlagen sind das war
schon eindrucksvoll wird aber trotzdem
auf diese zeit kommen wo die ja wo die
gegensätze viel stärker waren es war ja
nicht nur in bayern gegen den hanseat es
war der katholik gegen den protestanten
das war die lager waren doch viel
heftiger allerdings viel härter woran
lag das dass das so heftig war und wie
wurden die auseinandersetzung geführt
es hat insgesamt in der gesellschaft
noch sehr viel mehr gegensätze gegeben
über spd hatte godesberg erst eine
relativ kurze zeit tritt liegend vorher
waren die gegensätze noch viel viel
höher
es war eine zeit wo jetzt sag ich mal
dass aus sicht der csu wie auch er noch
mühe hat damit zu erkennen dass nicht
von der union der kanzler gestellt
worden ist
erst große koalition aber dann willy
brandt und helmut schmidt
wobei uns erinnere mich an einen
wahlkampf den wir in bayern unter dem
motto geführt haben einmal neid abt
langte platte made gedacht dass es sehr
schnell diese episode der spd wieder
gedreht werden kann
und natürlich waren die handelnden
personen das sehr viel polemische ein
strauß erinnert an dieses legendäre
gespräch bei einer wahl zwischen franz
josef strauß und helmut schmidt in einer
elefantenrunde
da ging es ja zur sache das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen das würde
heute gar nicht mehr so passieren
ich glaube das war auch eine typfrage
glaube dass damals auch mehr auf typen
aufeinander prallten die so gestrickt
waren das die die politische
auseinandersetzung hertha wirkte wenn
ich noch anfügen darf strauss der
natürlich bei uns eine dominierende
rolle in der csu gespielt hat hat wird
diese auseinandersetzungen oft berichtet
aber dann jeweils wenn man intern war
mit großem respekt von der kenntnis von
der argumentation
dieses helmut schmidt den handel als
gegner ernst genommen natürlich als
erster linie als gegner aber als jemand
der ein schwergewicht ist mit dem es
sich schwertut war das bei ihnen auslöst
rücken haben den gegner ernst genommen
oder war das sozusagen einfach nur das
musste man ja also eher waren den ganzen
wesentlichen punkten der strittigen
politik damals auf der anderen seite
also was wir völlig außer acht gelassen
als auch die ganze ökologie da überhaupt
kein verständnis dafür gehabt also heute
hängt sich dass jede partei an und im
bundestag ist ist auf kleinigkeiten
einzelne einzelne kleinigkeiten ist das
konsens der war ja doch nicht zeitgemäß
und kontroversen heute nicht mehr es
gibt nicht mehr die starken gegensätzen
es gibt nicht mehr diese grundsätzlichen
gegensätzen dass hier ein sagen das ist
alles spinnerei da was ihr mit eurer
ökologie und mit klima und so da wollt
hat ja glaube ich auch irgendwann mal
so'n spruch gemacht über das klima
erwärmung irgendwie das hat ja alles
überhaupt nicht ernst genommen was heute
15 jahren 20 jahre vorher mit einem feld
können was ich bemerkenswert finde ist
dass er vor allen dingen im alter ich
kann das ein bisschen nachvollziehen
dass er sich danach sehr geprägt war
offenbar gerade im alter noch von den
kriegserfahrungen
also ich glaube seine politik gegenüber
russland das hat etwas damit zu tun dass
er als soldat in diesem schrecklichen
krieg gegen gegen russland gewesen ist
und auch sein sein hochhalten der
europäischen union der europäischen
jedes da kann ich ihn verfolgen das sag
ich fast genauso ich sage das ist muss
so dahin
gerade deutschland muss eingebunden sein
und das müssen so feste bindungen sein
dass in mitteleuropa in europa so etwas
nicht wieder passieren kann
und da hat er die leeren begriff name da
hat er auch mal ein gesichtspunkt ist
ganz wichtig er hat er war ja ein 80 mal
sehr krank also wohl viele dachten es
steht auf der kippe ich glaube der
bürger bewusstlos und dass er danach 81
bis 2015 jetzt das sind 34 jahre oder so
dem mars wieder aktiv werden konnte und
in dem maße sich auch nicht nur auf sich
und seine umwelt euro oder seinem
unmittelbaren leute zurückgezogen hat
sondern immer noch diesen welt blickte
hat das findet man ganz ganz selten an
den redaktionskonferenzen teil und
belehrte viele kolleginnen und kollegen
herbeck was lernt die spd heute noch von
helmut schmidt
ich glaube dass man die tatsache dass
man in der tat eine intellektuelle
durchdringung von themen das
vorausdenken das globale denken
verbinden kann mit ganz klaren und
konsequenten entscheidungen im alltag
das ist eine lehre die bleibt uns auch
immer gesagt das hat er selber erzählt
aber auch kabinettsmitglieder von ihm im
kabinett wird da nicht lange rum gemacht
da muss jeder seine position klar kennen
darlegen und dann wird entschieden
das habe ich mir auch vorgenommen ich
muss sagen das funktioniert dass man
kann sehr vieles lernen in der art und
weise und ich habe immer bewundert habe
noch vor wenigen jahren
da ist er in einem sat gesetz hat schwer
gehört valeries christa war mit dabei
war in koblenz und er hat zu diesem
zeitpunkt auch er krank gewirkt und dann
ist auf die bühne kulturamt sitzen reden
und dieser sehr große saal war nach
wenigen sätzen in einer weise aufmerksam
und hat seinen ökonomischen ausführungen
nicht nur gefolgt sondern hat gespürt
die leute warten darauf wie er die dinge
entwickelt und wie er sie darlegt und so
etwas ist nun
fantastisch das kann man nicht anders
sein dass man ja auch seine großen
verdienste dass er sozusagen zusammen
mit the star die gipfeltreffen ins leben
gerufen hatte also vorgänger von g7 all
diese dinge wo er ja wirklich ein motor
war er vor etwas voran getrieben war
wir leben doch was würden sie denn sagen
was sollte die spd den von ihm lernen
denn die wahlergebnisse zu seinen zeiten
waren besser als die umfragen ja gut ich
weiß wir sind erstens muss man sagen das
macht zwei abklingen sind andere zeiten
aber ich glaube vielleicht sollte die
spd von ihm lernen auch mehr mut zu
haben bei dem stehen zu entscheidungen
sie manchmal gefällt hat ich glaube dass
sie das jetzt mal auf die agenda 2010
hatte man ja immer so den eindruck
eigentlich waren wir die nicht so
richtig gewollt ich glaube dass wir
unter schmidt so nicht passiert glaube
schmidt war einer der auch seine partei
dazu getrieben hat zu sagen so wir
stehen jetzt und wir gehen jetzt
gemeinsam durch ich bin noch eines sagen
ich glaube helmut schmidt hat auch in
seinem alter gerade noch gewarnt vor
einer überheblichkeit der deutschen in
der in der gesamten politik gerade bei
der griechenland krise kam dass immer
wieder auch bei ihm raus das ging ja
sogar so weit dass er sagte wir müssen
nicht alle unsere demokratischen formen
überall in die ganze welt transportieren
das könnte vielleicht sogar eher zu
konflikten führen also er war da doch
eher auf der gerade was die rolle
deutschlands an ging in der welt auch
zwar einerseits ja wir sind eine starke
nation aber wir dürfen uns nicht so
verhalten wie einst die preußenkönige
und meinen wir seien die einzigen
das kann auch wieder die souveränität
der einzelnen länder
ganz obenan gestellt und auch in
menschenrechtsfragen hat er wenig
verständnis gehabt wenn man gesagt hat
wenn die kanzlerin jetzt da hingeht oder
mit dem redet mit dem potenzial das hat
ja gar kein fachstelle rolle gerade was
china
ich würde schon ein bisschen
differenzierter sehen ich glaube es ist
schon ein unterschied ob man
menschenrechte ernst nimmt oder ob man
sie die außenpolitik verkürzt auf diese
frage von ritualen in einer diskussion
hat der heutige bundesaußenminister
gesagt nicht finde er hat völlig recht
wir müssen aufpassen dass solche rituale
nicht mehr nach innen in die
bundesrepublik hineingeredet werden als
dass sie wirklich helfen
häufig ist wenn man es geschickt macht
das eher kontraproduktiv für die
menschen um deren träger sollten deshalb
will ich glaube auch da ist ein bisschen
differenzierung regenbogen man hat dann
sehr schnell die falschen freunde und da
gibt's bei helmut schmidt eingang
italien die macher als diktatoren und so
weiter nach vorn sind und von allen
kritisieren ich habe bei ihm zu sitzen
und gerade über solche fragen wir haben
über afrika und initiativen geräte hat
ein ganz differenziertes bild von den
potentaten dort gehabt und auch davon
wie sich manche leute auf die hoffnung
gesetzt hatten in afrika dann entwickelt
haben also ich hab dann sehr
differenziertes bild erlebt und eine
nähe zu zu diktaturen also das müsste
mir jemand zuerst einmal belegen kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen dass empfunden
es war eine zeit wo die frage der nicht
einmischung in die innere politik alles
anderes land dann ist ganz grosse
voraussetzung war um überhaupt politik
machen zu können
willy brandt hat mit den mensch mit den
regierungen im ostblock gespräche
geführt und nicht als erstes gesagt ihr
müsst demokratisch werden es war die
zeit nur mal natürlich erstmal den
anderen auch in seiner andersartigkeit
hinnehmen musste wenn man mit rostenden
wurde konnte man damals ganz bestimmt
sicher nicht als erstes sagen dass die
demokratie in unserem sinn da nicht
entsprechend geführt war es war wichtig
trotzdem die gespräche zu führen
es war auch wichtig den eigenen
standpunkt zu haben
und das ist dass ich kann jetzt sagen
was spd von ihm landes sondern was
insgesamt politik lernen sollte dass man
selber sich einen klaren standpunkt
erarbeitet die ihn auch vertritt nicht
als allererste meinungsumfragen dass man
sich auch dezidiert äussert so dass die
menschen verstehen was jemand will und
nicht vor lauter wenn und aber dann die
meinungen haben dass jemand keine eigene
meinung hat er war jemand der ganz mutig
zur seine entscheidungen gestanden hat
dann kann man sich auch reibt und
demokratie ist doch das rede- und
gegenargumente und gegenrede argumente
und gegenargumente aufeinandertreffen
und daraus dann sozusagen wie ihr leiter
system mäßiger weg wir erleben im moment
dass eine kanzlerin die zu ihren
entscheidungen steht eben in umfragen
runtergeht nicht angela merkel mit dem
süden zu den entscheidungen einsetzen
wir schaffen das wäre das auch ein
schmidt satz es ist immer schwer zu
sagen was würde jemand in einer solchen
situation sagen ich glaube eine geste
der menschlichkeit wäre durchaus schmidt
auch nicht fremd gewesen aber
wahrscheinlich hätte einige konditionen
dazu formuliert wenn er gesagt hätte wir
schaffen das wie schaffen wir es und was
sind bedingungen das davon gehe ich aus
weil er doch sehr differenziert in den
dingen war und sehr klar dann in der
durch argumentieren als
erhaltungstherapie stopp aber ob er das
in einer solchen situation gesagt wird
da habe ich große zweifel in richtung
ausländerpolitik hat er dass die
gastarbeiter anwerbung beendet alle
gesagt hat es gibt in der bevölkerung zu
viele ressentiments zu viel unruhe zu
viel sagen auch in der arbeiterschaft
deswegen war das die das erste mal der
früheren miss der weiß dass noch sehr
genau weil wir das sehr oft zitiert
haben dass helmut schmidt damals den
anwerbestopp für gastarbeiter
erlassen hat um eben auch zuwanderung
stärker zu steuern und zu begrenzen war
natürlich auch nicht zeit überhaupt
arbeitslosigkeit bei der ersten großen
krise ölkrise höher gegangen
die frage was ihm wurde immer gesagt er
war bei der katastrophe in hamburg bei
der flugkatastrophe 20 war er der macher
er hat sich hinweggesetzt über
irgendwelche grundsätze und das würde ja
zu diesem wir schaffen das eigentlich
passen sagt hätte schaffen dass ich doch
noch muss er ganz klar sein man kann die
situation nicht vergleichen
man kann wirklich nicht vergleichen die
die flutkatastrophe in hamburg mit dem
was jetzt passiert eine völkerwanderung
das ist es ja letzten endes vielleicht
hätte helmut schmidt aber jetzt ist es
auch spekulation bestimmte maßnahmen
schneller und er eingeleitet
und vielleicht schneller auch
durchgedrückt also es im moment der fall
jetzt dieses etwas hin und her zwischen
ja kommen jetzt nicht kommen
die einteilung die arbeit der behörden
zu koordinieren
das wäre vielleicht etwas schneller und
härter gegangen aber ich sag nochmal man
kann glaube ich diese beiden situationen
nicht vergleichen und die zeiten seiner
kanzlerschaft waren auch eine etwas
langsamere zeiten es gab kein internet
diese art von medien wie wir sie heute
haben wir druck war sicherlich nicht
ganz so groß wir schaffen das also ich
kann mir das nicht vorstellen natürlich
haben sie recht wenn er tätig geworden
wer er war ein macher ich glaube das
wird jeder das kann man dieses attribut
kann ich nicht nehmen aber ich zweifle
ob er diese flüchtlings die die bilder
diese in meinem fernsehen gesehen hat ab
die ihn dazu gebracht hätten eine solche
politik zu sagen gut wir machen jetzt
freecom esskultur und also hätte da
glaube ich anders reagiert als die
kanzlerin
er hätte wenn so eine entscheidung
gefallen wäre hätte er
konsequenter gemacht da würde ich das
auch vorne überzeugt und das werde ich
auch der kanzlerin jetzt vor dass sie
zwar den spruch gesagt hat und auch sich
dann so öffentlichkeit präsentiert hat
auch überall feiern lassen
in diesem punkt auch zurecht aber dass
sie dann hat mich sofort ingesamt punkt
12 34 das machen wir jetzt alles um das
auch wirklich so schaffen und uns somit
auch gebracht der wäre vor die kameras
getreten und hätte eine ansprache an das
volk erhalten
nach der tagesschau ich glaube mein land
etwas mehr ein mann der große gefühle
zeigte aber er hat ja eine sehr lange
ehe geführt also hat ja ein gesegnetes
langes leben und ein sehr langes
eheleben er welche rolle spielte
eigentlich dieses privatleben und wie
wichtig war loki schmidt wien
ja man hat ja das gefühl wenn man den
beiden begegnete oder auch wenn man sie
nur auf dem bildschirm erlebte da ist
eine symbiose der besonderen art da gibt
es übereinstimmungen da gibt es heftige
diskussionen untereinander aber es ist
eben sind zwar menschen die zueinander
passen und auch zueinander stehen dass
es schon etwas besonderes und ich glaube
dass ich in solchen verhaltensweisen von
ihm eben auch die tiefe verankerung
internet evangelischen religion
widergespiegelt hat es ja nicht so dass
da jemand nur der macher war sondern
dabei auch ein wertegerüst zumindest
habe ich das so eingeschätzt und erlebt
da waren wertegerüst das eben nicht vor
sich hergetragen aber tief im inneren
eine menge damit zu tun hatte eben
christliche werte für sich gelten zu
lassen
ich habe den eindruck dass nicht immer
mit unserer evangelischen kirche in
völliger übereinstimmung gewesen die
ziemlich heftig gewesen sind
wahrscheinlich nicht auf die werte
bezogen auf die kirchlichen instanzen
und nein ich glaube schon dass ein ganz
zuverlässige kirchgänger war was sicher
jemand der eine ganz ganz tiefe werte
beziehung hatte und sich weit über die
gegenwart hinaus gedanken gemacht hat
das hat man bei dem gespräch mit ihm
dann der anfang 2004 25 habe ich mich
mehrfach mit ihm getroffen
da hat man das gemerkt dass sie dinge
beschäftigen die einfach mit der
existenz des menschen insgesamt zu tun
haben und dass er da schon jemand ist er
auf eine große ethisch und sittliche
verankerung wert legt
was könnten dann jüngere menschen noch
von ihm lernen oder ist es so jemand wo
man sagt ja gott der 96 jahre alt
geworden und sozusagen ein opa und der
von dem kann ich eigentlich nichts mehr
lernen können von ihm lernen was ich
auch immer versucht zu sagen dass es
sich lohnt solange man das körperlich
kann solange man gesundheitlichen
voraussetzungen hat sich einzumischen
und zwar ganz dezidiert das hat er ja
wirklich bis in die letzten zeit gemacht
und ich glaube auch seine große
reputation die ja offenbar in der
bevölkerung hat die stammt aus dieser
zeit die stattliche aus 1982 oder 83 ich
kenne jetzt umfragen damals nicht aber
nicht annähernd das prestige was er
heute hatte sondern das ist eine
reaktion darauf dass er klartext redet
dass er in sachen sachen ausspricht die
andere nicht mehr aussprechen die immer
versuchen irgendwie warum und dass er
klare positionen hat und dass man hier
auch nachvollziehen können
ich glaube dass man sich einmischen soll
das hat er wirklich gab es zwischen
ihnen
eigentlich mal irgendwie eine annäherung
ich glaube auch mal überlegt was ich
habe mit vielen stand diskutiert auch
über die zeit damals auch mit herr
beckstein auch darüber und über polizei
und ein wirksamer aber ich habe mir dann
auch manchmal überlegt wäre das wohl
möglich mit helmut schmidt weil ich
könnte ihm einige sagen was ich ihnen
aber jetzt hier nicht sagen vielleicht
zum nachdenken gebracht hätte aber ich
glaube nicht ich glaube ich wäre nicht
angekommen und das sage ich ganz ganz
fertig also mir fällt vor allem auch
offen gestanden etwas sein was man nicht
unbedingt als vorbild ansieht nämlich
dass er zu allen zeiten und unmöglichen
zeiten geraucht hat wie ein schlot das
ist ja heute nicht mehr korrekt aber was
ich meine was eine aufrechte haltung
eine aufrechte gesinnung zu seiner
überzeugung zu stehen dafür einzutreten
dass was man selber für richtig hält
auch als botschaft an andere zu setzen
das ist sicher etwas was meine ich für
jeden jungen menschen vorbild sein
sollte wenn ich sagen darf ich glaube
muss ich auch ein bisschen hüten zu
sagen was können junge menschen jetzt
lernen von jemand der in einer oder zwei
generationen früher gelebt und
gearbeitet und gewirkt hat aber wahr zu
nehmen wie er mit den dingen umgegangen
ist das glaube ich kann helfen sich eine
eigene meinung zu bilden und einen
standpunkt herauszukristallisieren
es ist ja nicht so dass man mit einem
standpunkt geboren wird und den an leben
lang vertritt sondern man muss ihn
finden und die eigenen bezüge immer
klarer hervortreten dann für sich ganz
allein und ich glaube das kann man auch
wenn man die bücher liest über ihn
das kann man schon erfahren und dann
kann man in dem sinne auch was lernen
aber dicht jetzt übertragen das wäre
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen zu viel
erwartet war er zu hart mit sich und
auch mit anderen auch gerade in diesen
auseinandersetzungen
er war ist sicher hart aber wir gucken
ja niemanden rein und wenn jemand eine
solche entscheidung treffen muss die
bedeuten kann wie bei hanns martin
schleyer dass es den tod eines menschen
bedeutet dann ist das eine
ungeheuerliche herausforderung
ich sag mal soldaten irgendwo hin zu
schicken die auch menschen sterben
können ist auch eine ungeheure
herausforderung aber eine ganz bestimmte
person und von der ganz klaren
entscheidung gehe ich auf die drohung
ein oder sage ich ich muss die
staatsregierung hier einordnen dann zu
entscheiden und zu stehen
man kann nur sagen alle die in
verantwortung sind können sich so etwas
nicht wünschen es ist furchtbar wenn man
sowas entscheiden muss und vielleicht
entsteht daraus auch eine gewisse härte
die man zum eigenschutz auch braucht
nämlich an diskussionen über die
entscheidung im krisenstab er hat mir
damals als innenminister gesagt dass man
in
verantwortung auch für ganz besonders
schwierige entscheidungen gestellt ist
wo man in jedem fall schuldig wird es
gibt situationen wo es nicht an
eindeutig richtig dann eindeutig falsch
gibt sondern wo man in jedem falle ein
stück schuld auf sich lädt und ich weiß
dass es ihm sehr betroffen gemacht hat
und exakter dass seine entscheidung
sozusagen auch damit das todesurteil mit
über schleier gewesen ist das hat ihn
sehr beschäftigt er hat gesagt zusage
ende beschäftigt bis zu sagen glaubt
aber umgekehrt hat er dann immer
herausgehoben
die alternative wäre dass der
rechtsstaat nachgibt und damit
staatsversagen welche ausführungen und
auswirkungen ist für weitere die dann
als geist hätten genommen werden können
und diese abwägung und einer ganz ganz
erheblichen bewusstsein der
verantwortung
das ist etwas wo dann das gespräch
gegangen ist auf die frage
gesinnungsethik verantwortung tätig der
politiker hat die aufgabe die
verantwortung abzuwägen die folgen
auszurechnen was kommt am letzten endes
raus ich glaube dass wenn man die
wirkungen auf ihn selber sieht man
mogadischu mitdenken muss da war ja
wieder eine solche entscheidung dann
fällig zu sein oder nicht und das sind
schon dinge die prägen menschen sicher
für erleben und dann halt eben auch der
tod von ensslin rasper und bader dann in
der nacht danach nach der stimmung der
reiseströme was ist wenn wir dann noch
ganz kurz zu kommen wenn wir da jetzt
gerade darüber reden was ist denn da
ihre stärkste erinnerungen an diese zeit
und wenn sie da das auch nicht weil ich
mich an helmut schmidt gedacht
in einer richtung schon ich will das
jetzt wirklich nicht hier aus führen
weil dazu dass man das näher erklären
die frage ist ob es auch andere
alternativen gegeben hat damals also
gespräche
wir haben schon das rauchen von helmut
schmidt angesprochen dass er immer
überall geraucht hat und auch ein hohes
alter erreicht hat
trotz oder gerade wegen der zigaretten
wir wissen es nicht es waren zigaretten
es gab in der zeit dessen herausgeber er
war eine rubrik auf eine zigarette mit
helmut schmidt dann immer und dich
deswegen angesprochen weil die frage
rauchverbot in meiner amtszeit als
ministerpräsident eines der
furchtbarsten wir haben mal
nachgebessert und letztlich hat das volk
in einem volksentscheid in bayern dann
entschieden das ist ganz klar dass ich
weiß dass sie nicht geraucht haben
früher aber wenn sie jetzt noch eine
zigarette rauchen könnt mit helmut
schmidt also eine frage nach stellen
könnten für eine zigarettenlänge bin
sicher noch wissen von ihnen ich würde
ihn gerne fragen wie er denn in der
phase hat das ja sehr bewusst alles
erlebt wie er in der phase für sich
selber sein leben reflektiert hat das
wäre glaube ich ungeheuer spannend über
frühere zeiten hat er geschrieben aber
in der endphase des lebens dann noch
einmal zu reflektieren und türen wie
geht ein mensch mit all dem um diesen
ruhm und diesen schweren zeiten und dass
das wäre glaube ich
hochspannend mehr geworden hingenommen
ich glaube ich würde ihn fragen warum er
da bin ich dann noch mal war jetzt
ströbele
warum er eigentlich die ökologische
bewegung so unterschätzt hat weil das
fand ich im nachhinein bei ihm etwas was
ich nicht so ganz
wir erklären konnte ein mann der
eigentlich so weit auch gedacht hat
warum er das
nicht so gesehen hat dass da etwas kommt
was diese gesamte politische landschaft
was auch die gesamte weltpolitik sein
würden so was ähnliches ich hätte ihn
gefragt warum sind sie eigentlich ein
konservativer in ihrer ganzen politik
gewesen solange sie die bestimmt haben
und war nicht in der lage zu begreifen
die neuen überlegungen ideen die
notwendig waren damit die entwicklung in
europa in deutschland voran geht und
warum ist es erst in ihrem hohen alter
herr braun alter dann so weit gekommen
dass sie das auch nicht revidiert habe
ich es jedenfalls nicht sondern das sie
dann wirklich sich gedanken gemacht
haben über das hinaus und versucht haben
probleme anzugehen die welt geschehen
wir haben noch zeit für einen zigaretten
mich würde interessieren was sagt helmut
schmidt wie wird die entwicklung
zwischen abendland und morgenland
weitergehen wie wird zwischen
christentum und islam weitergehen weil
er gerade ja in seinen letzten jahren
sich eben mit dem grundlegend fragen
sehr beschäftigt hat das würde mich
brennend interessieren wie er das für
die zukunft einschätzt
okay ganz herzlichen dank für dieses
erinnern an helmut schmidt bundeskanzler
großer staatsmann und ein vorbild für
viele deutsche ich bin freue mich dass
sie heute an unserer zuschauer waren und
morgen sind wir mit der physiker bis
dahin